Kim you were the surprise og on the
stage today at the Oh Gees panel walk it
out seeing the fans what did that mean
to you the what is it when you walk out
and applause no not the they the way
they treated me when I walked out I'm
looking for the word mine I was so
grateful they just they yelled they
scream they clapped I so much love and
I'm just so grateful and it made me feel
overwhelmed like joy I feel grateful
enjoyed so thank you you seem to be at a
grateful enjoy place in your life right
now why is that is there special
somebody in your life right now yeah me
me I found me you know it took me 55
years to find me and it's just me I'm in
a really good place today not just today
but I found this this I found me and it
took some work but I got here and just
feel so good and I you know my kids are
great and I have two wonderful grandsons
Huxley and Hunter and my sisters you
know is having a great relationship with
them but I'm I do a lot of work on
myself and I'm a Reiki practitioner I do
work I was spiritually and energetically
and I know just I love life that's
really great to hear and I know those
little babies are kind of your pride and
joy right now but are you looking for
love right now are you just focused on
Grandma life
I'm really happy and today I'm just so
grateful just you know III I said a
prayer a while back you know and I said
like I just want to wake up every day
and feel alive feel happy and and and
want to feel a zest for life and I just
wasn't having that like you've been the
only thing was I had that but it was
just seeing my kids and to see my
grandkids and if I wasn't with them like
I just I didn't I just see home and I
loved to be at home I love my garden my
garden fulfills me my gym I work out
really hard every day but I just didn't
have that and I have it today and I just
like God answered my prayers I can't I
wake up sometimes in the middle of the
night I'm like oh my gosh it's the wait
time Oh
when does borning get here because I
can't wait to wake up I'm so excited to
go live every day now how did you find
that in yourself did it just come one
day or I was working and I would you
know through Instagram was scrolling
through probably stalking my children
yeah looking for pictures and things and
I saw dr. Joe Dispenza is the spiritual
activator or single these things and I
started listening for them and it's just
like three or four words from these men
and like things about energetic you
working the chakras and I started
working in
I did everything these people said and I
started doing the live streams and and
the webinars and I was taking notes and
and I you know stand outside I get
charged for the Sun I was doing
everything I worked each little point at
my body it's what hurts what pain hurt
you and I had to bring it out and lay it
on the table and maybe go away and I did
it I healed I had a lot of work but it
hurt you had to take out everything that
hurts he's writing your book kind of the
same process
oh yeah let me take that back that was
it was kind of like around the same time
dude
writing the book and looking back at
every single thing in your life had ever
hurt you know the good stuff - Bobby I
was born
oh so free was born and we travel to
Californian and my parents got divorced
oh yeah better that was on and then the
next beautiful story and then oh wow
remember that oh that hurt but it was
kind of like while I was going through
these moments I was doing this work and
it just kind of all blended and I
thought I was gonna cry every day and
sometimes I would cry but it was almost
like I would cry with joy it'll release
yes it was actually that was hard but
but look what happened after lookup and
then and so it's been a beautiful
experience and I think everybody's gonna
like it and so I'm excited
very cool and I love that you Kathy and
Kyle or Hall in a good place now how did
you come back together
I I think mikail was texting me and I
was not having it you know and I think
just think through the spirit experience
where I met my open heart my open mind
just kind of put me in a place of I
think I just wrote her and said like
need to put this down let's put this
away
life is too it can be too short I just I
love you and I miss you
and she loved me miss me
help my kids but life is just too
beautiful to waste this and let's just
holidays she wrote me back holidays are
here right around I don't just like it
just happened
together it seems like this whole year
has kind of been a moment of everything
coming together and we've loved how open
you've been about everything in your
life how is the sobriety journey right
now it's I don't have room for anything
I have complete clarity especially doing
like my spiritual work and being a Reiki
practitioner I don't have room to be
anything foggy or it is even about
sobriety as much as I don't I don't want
to hear because it's gonna interfere
with what I do other ways and what I'm
doing so sobriety spiritually energetic
lies there isn't room for that in my
life today
so it all lines up it's just like that
we know you just shot for the new season
with brandy and Eileen was there what
was it like having the whole gang back
together well what are you talking about
because there are a lot of them there
actually it was really fun not gonna lie
there are a few very awkward moments
Syrena maybe your what you know awkward
moments with a few different people okay
but I will say you know it was for
Children's Hospital I don't know that
there wasn't a little spat here and
there I was very good okay so I know but
I think there were just some really
awkward moments but all in all I had a
great time and my sisters and I had a
great time you can see I think it was
posted on Instagram p.m. we had fun the
Wilson Phillips those girls I love them
all my heart I grew up with China I know
Kearney very well
and by all the girl and it was just so
touching and so beautiful and raising
money for the Children's Hospital was so
beautiful and my sister knocked it out
of the ballpark last question here you
scared us over the summer with a post
about a health scare how is your health
how are you doing I'm waiting for I'm
okay I'm still like I'm recovering now I
didn't know if I'd be able to travel but
it was a breast cancer if yeah it was
breast cancers here so I'm waiting I'm
okay I think
and I know I'm okay I know I'm okay and
I actually just called it off a little
while ago to get my final biopsies back
and I I know I'm good
I know I know I'm great
[Music]